she was like what are you doing and i
was like oh i'm selling feed pics
she was like what do you mean i'm like
well mom i just take pics of my feet and
sell them for like fifty dollars
she was shook
[Music]
hi i'm michaela i'm 25 i live in
minneapolis minnesota
i create content on youtube and i'm also
an only fans creator hello my name is
chase i am also an only fans creator
and i started through tick tock got a
big following
and then that's why i went over to only
fans and instagram and stuff like that
hi i'm mika i'm from las vegas
i started doing only fans kind of
last march when i made a viral porno on
pornhub
with my boyfriend about kovic to spread
awareness hi my name is zamara
i am 24 years old i have been in sex
work for five years so i started at only
fans
a year ago last february 2020 and it's
been
a success ever since hi everyone my name
is myra aka motha
i'm an only fans content creator my
promotion everything is mostly based off
of twitter and i have a regular
non-device as well
hey guys my name is asher i'm 26. i
actually started only fans at the
beginning of the pandemic
and ever since that's been what i've
been relying on
the government's failing us and i needed
my money
influencers and celebrities have ruined
only fans
let's start with michaela i said
somewhat agree
chase somewhat disagree mika
disagree zamara strongly agree
myra somewhat agree asher
somewhat disagree i truly feel like
celebrities have completely taken away
the opportunity
of small content creators basically
relying on a platform
that they depend on for their whole
income i feel like celebrities
you know already have the upper hand
with being having a title being rich
having a title of having money
and their art like their own like ego of
being a celebrity but to some of us this
is our lifestyle this is something that
we depend on this is something that
we use every single day working full
time to meet and reach our goals
there's like both pros and cons that's
why i said somewhat disagree because i
understand your point of view but then i
also
seen that like they're bringing more
notice to the platform
so they're bringing a lot more people to
only fans because when i first started
two years ago
there was not a lot of audience on only
fans and not a lot of people knew what
it was
and a lot of people thought it was like
terrible celebrities caused
temporary hiccups and issues so you know
when we have those issues like bella
thorne
and other celebrities just creating
these profiles intending that you know
we're basically want to bait and switch
these people it causes a temporary
problem because you have that influx of
people coming in now just to see that
one person so once a new person comes on
or a new celebrity comes on it's like
yeah now don't forget about only fans
because you know once you don't feel
like paying fifty dollars a month for
you know trey songz you'll go pay for
your five dollar
you know a month only fans person and
that's when we start bringing it in so
yeah definitely with the awareness
because
honestly with sex work almost any
promotion is good promotion
a lot of the stories that we hear from
celebrities on only fans tend to be
about scams or things that take away our
credibility as creators on only fans so
then when people hear that we might be
doing only fans they only
think about those scandals and assume oh
so you're just scamming people for money
or something and it's like no
they're actually like really authentic
ways that we can build an audience and
earn income from it
like if you want to make money on this
and you have your audience like go for
it but do it correctly like
don't take advantage of people don't lie
about what you're selling like
do it right i make a lot of money
michaela i said strongly agree
chase i said somewhat agree
mika agree
zamara strongly agree mira
somewhat disagree asher agree
i do this for fun and that being said i
make
more than enough than i could ever
imagine
and i'm on track to retire in the next
five years
so that's that's all i could ever want
yeah i wanted to bring up that only fans
is only one of my 14 streams of revenue
right now
and i want to make sure that if
something happens to one of my streams
of revenue that i'm going to be okay
which is why i try so hard to have so
many
that's kind of why i love only fans
because it does allow that financial
freedom to take
a big portion of income and be able to
use that to help further your future
whether you're investing into
a project um property or even just like
the stock market it kind of allows us to
push ourselves into the next step in our
later years in life and really look out
for each other which i really like
i put strongly agree because i've never
had money like this in my life as a 24
year old woman
i was making like 16 an hour at trader
joe's a year ago
and i have made over like
i mean six figures but like a lot of six
figures
and i just don't know any other field of
work that would pay me that type of
money
you got to be patient with yourself i
think with stuff like this it takes a
lot of time
patience and consistency and you're just
not gonna make an only fans
post a vote video a video or a photo of
yourself and make
six figures it just doesn't work like
that it's taking me five
long hard working years to say that like
i have the things that i do and i work
hard for them
that's why i think with only fans or
just working online in general and for
yourself the cap is off
you can make as much as you want to make
if you really try and you put in the
strides and the efforts to make that
much money
a lot of people ask me if they should do
only fans and i'm like it's really
relative to you
like let's say you have 100 followers on
instagram and that's all you have you
probably won't make much money because
only fans doesn't really promote you
that much like you mainly get promotion
from your other websites
your other socials or other whatever you
do so like it depends on if you think
you could get your followers following
you to actually follow you
and actually like pay money for your
content then you can make a lot of money
you just can't expect things to happen
out from nothing and i think that's a
big misconception when it comes to only
fans
everybody thinks that we basically like
sit on our ass all day and don't do
anything like we're editing videos we're
editing photos
we're picking out times to drop this
video and that and you know
those things take time even with my nine
to five it's like i have to work at
eight hour shift and then go beat my
face
and get ready and put on lingerie to
take pictures and sweat
we don't talk enough about the work that
goes into it everybody just knows the
benefits and that's
that's you know that's where we get
my family knows that i'm an only fans
creator
michaela i chose agree chase
i chose strongly agree mika
strongly agree zamara strongly agree
myra strongly agree asher
agree i first told my mom
one day when we were actually at the
lake and
i was taking feet pics and
she was like what are you doing and i
was like oh i'm selling feed pics
and she was like what do you mean i'm
like well mom i just take
pics of my feet and sell them for like
50 dollars she was shook
as for my grandparents um they always
ask me if i found a job yet because
i told them i lost my job at the
beginning of the pandemic
and i'm like don't worry about me i got
you they would have a heart attack i
think one of my cousins
sent a text to my brother after probably
seeing a youtube video and told him like
your sister's doing porn
and then he showed that to my mom and
she kind of confronted me about it
and you know i kind of had to like talk
them off the ledge and being like okay
well
let's define porn here and telling them
exactly not exactly
but kind of explaining how i was earning
money what i was posting and
my limits because you know i think we
all have boundaries with ourselves as to
what we post or what we choose not to
share on that platform and
a big misconception i think when people
hear that you do only fans is that
you automatically might post x y and z
when maybe you only post
x and y but not z and etc i initially
out just outwardly told my mom but i
waited until i made over a thousand
dollars on only fans so i can justify
me doing this however my father found
out by
he saw me in pornhub when i finally
moved from virginia to philadelphia
my dad came and helped me move out and
we basically had the heart to heart he
was like you know
i was doing the same you were doing in
the 90s with a camcorder so
be safe you know i loved you and he was
like
and you get it honest and he was like
but i know anything that you do
you do it exceptionally well i basically
had the same experience as myra
with her mom i just told my parents what
i was doing
because i had to tell them somehow
because i was making this money
they could see my bank account at the
time because i was like connected
through theirs
and they actually found it very like
humorous and interesting but they were
very worried
it may affect because my mom at that
point still wanted me to go to med
school because she's in the medical
field
but then once i talk to her about how i
want to
take the path of social media and not go
to school right now or at least take a
break from school
she was kind of on the fence about that
and very worried like because
they're they're pretty old so like
they're not like aware that you can make
money in so many different ways nowadays
so it took her a while
it took both them a while to wrap their
head around it but once they came around
they were actually very supportive i'm
paranoid about protecting my privacy
michaela what answer did you choose
i said strongly agree chase
i put somewhat agree mika
somewhat agree zamara
disagree myra somewhat disagree
asher somewhat agree
so the first thing i remember is someone
hacked my snapchat
and found my cell phone number my email
address and a ton of private
photos not necessarily explicit just
like my personal life on there
then i occasionally unfortunately get
people commenting my address on my
youtube videos
i got this one like in the middle of the
night from this troll being like wow
like do you live here with my full
home address where my parents and family
live i've
learned a lot through this last year to
try to become even more private with my
information because unfortunately
you know it's just so public online it's
been really tricky and i've like
even started therapy again this year
because my anxiety has become so high
with
every notification that i get on my
phone so it just sucks that there are
people out there not really looking out
for anyone's good intentions and taking
advantage of people's platforms or their
privacy
i just had a lot of experiences this
year with that
not during sex work before i started sex
work i had a stalker which
kind of made me question whether or not
this is like a good line to go into
because of how public everything is i
mean i'm in a super secure neighborhood
i'm in
like we have a gun i can protect myself
if i need to
my boyfriend's a great shot too but
there's always
like in my mind and like well worst case
something could happen
i think i'm more worried for my family
than i am for myself though
i go under a stage name i i just keep
my privacy private i
am insecure about my body
let's start with michaela disagree
chase somewhat agree mika
disagree zamara somewhat agree
mira disagree asher
somewhat disagree i feel like
personally well i've been diagnosed with
like body dysmorphia so
that may make me biased about this
prompt when i first went to college i
lived in the dorms and so
we got we got the meal plan and i would
go to like
the cafeteria to get the foods and i
would just like couldn't eat not because
the food didn't look good like obviously
with school food so still kind of
but like i would like not eat for the
fact that
i wanted to keep my abs i wanted to keep
this keep this this and that and i would
like tell myself
and like talk to my parents when they
saw me like look in the mirror and like
talk about these things they'd be like
what is wrong with you like my i said my
mom's in the medical field
so she brought me into the actual office
so it was like a special type of body
it's morphe like a muscular dysmorphia i
never feel like i'm
muscular enough or lean enough so it's
like i don't feel i'm as defined as i
always should be even though
on from their point of view they're like
you're crazy like you look [ __ ]
you look fine like two almost three
years ago i was diagnosed
with uh anorexia nervosa i had a severe
eating disorder it started in the strip
club
that i worked in like 2018 2017
i think the pressure from seeing other
people go on stage and
you know make more money than me having
different body types than me it really
made me feel insecure about myself
so i kind of had to take a step back
from that and really like take a break
from that
i have to take care of myself do what
makes me happy and love myself because i
do believe
like being hard on yourself really does
reflect your content and show in your
content
you know the work you do put out and i
just think that's one important note to
always remember is to love yourself and
you come first and
you know health is wealth truly and i
love that and that's definitely what you
have to realize
but i know especially like it
exemplifies like the
hardness you put on yourself because
you're on stage like this is your job
this is
everyone's looking at you you know i'm
glad you shared that thank you
of course i have of course spent
years of not loving myself i've been fat
um in black so it's really
hard as a fat black woman to make your
way in the sex
industry without being completely
fetishized completely demoralized and
to be completely honest i pride myself
in like
not you know entertaining that like i
would never call myself a cow
you wouldn't hear me saying that i'm
about to get bred none of that i feel
like the sex work industry has
really helped me develop you know
for sure self-confidence where now when
i walk in the street i feel like i can
bag any man that i want
of course we all have our days where we
feel like we're just not up to car but
more often than not i feel good about
myself i love myself
and i like showing the world myself so
that's that's my opinion on it
what's awesome about only fans too is
that there are so many different
accounts and varieties of like shapes
and sizes and kinks and what people are
into
so your body or like whoever you are in
there like your brand
might be somebody's like perfect type
and yet someone that you
feel insecure compared to might not be
what they're into so there's just like
this
almost infinite platform of audiences
where it's like you are somebody's
perfect type
even if you don't look like someone that
you wish you looked like
yeah i really think michaela nailed it
on the head someone is going to be into
what you post
like no matter the kink no matter what
it is they're not going to see the same
flaws that you see
they're going to be horny let's go
i would rather have another job
michaela strongly disagree
chase disagree mika
strongly disagree zamara
disagree myra disagree
asher some would agree
i did the whole book by the book type of
like career path i
went to college i got a bachelor's in
communication
and i felt like i was following
something that i knew that wasn't for me
i feel like being into sex work now and
like fully like making it my full-time
job
has like helped me fall into who i am
more and build like my confidence more
i feel like it's just something i'm so
comfortable with especially with the
fact of like how much money that you
know that you can make on something like
this
if anything with the money that i do
make now i just want to invest in myself
and build my own company
and continue to grow that way and just
be always under my own
like name my own boss my own title i
never see myself working under anyone
ever again in my life like that's not
something i want to do that's something
i've learned from
only fans but i would love to
branch out from only fans and be doing
other things in music
or anything like that i think it would
be really cool to have like
like madonna has like she has the sex
book and like later down the line it's
like oh yeah go look back at
your sex book i
am not a full-time sex worker i have a
full-time nine-to-five job
only fans has really given me the
freedom to you know live the life i want
to live i'm happy doing the things that
i'm doing
however it would be really foolish of me
as i am
to you know get rid of my job because
this is my
legitimacy and you know i i never i
don't have jobs
that would really i'm not the
spokesperson for that company so it
doesn't matter
if i am sucking on the internet they
don't care they're not looking for myra
you know nobody's googling me and you're
like oh you're the one that helped me
i did not do the whole college thing i i
got some college credits under my belt
if i really want to ever go back
but even just the one year of doing
school it accumulated so much that
which thanks to only fans i've paid off
my boyfriend and i just got a tesla
we're planning on
doing road trips camping in the tesla
going around filming content in it
and i would never be able to do that
with just a basic nine to five
i think if i wasn't doing sex work i
would probably still just be like
a stay-at-home girlfriend cleaning
cooking
that's the life you don't necessarily
have to be sucking on only fans you can
make a cake only fans like it's
it's what you make it and you know just
being a content creator in this day and
age it's really a blessing that only
fans is
here because it's actually been a
lifeboat for
millions of people in this pandemic if
you want to be real
there's no way like i've never heard of
anything like this you know
where people have been put in such a
situation where our own government is
not helping us
and we are all hustlers at you know at
one time i think yeah i think these
conversations are really important to
erase the stigma around sex work and to
normalize
sex in general also i'm so thankful for
only fans allowing us to express
ourselves
sexually while instagram or tick tock or
anything like that
is constantly shutting down and
censoring voices
of lgbt or anything of that sort and i
think it's also
important to for us as a community of
creators or anything to stand against
the internet regulations that
people are the government is going to
put on the internet and things like that
it was good to meet you thank you guys
[Music]
we